[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today here is
with us in Miami Florida hi Peter
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you thank you how can we
help
so I I I'm wondering what role you think
I should play in helping my financially
irresponsible mother
[Music]
you know one of the things it's weird
about that question for a lot of us is
when we face that is it seems like money
is in a different category than other
misbehavior
if you changed out her misbehavior for
something else
a different kind of misbehavior or
irresponsibility
um what would the how would the answer
change it shouldn't really should it it
ought to be the same answer so in other
words if we wanted to go extreme and say
how do I help my mom who's addicted to
cocaine right well it wouldn't be give
her more
right it would be help her break the
habit and transform her life that's help
is not doing more of the bad thing
help is correcting the behaviors so and
of course the person that involves the
person on the other end wanting the help
yeah that's I usually run into parents
don't want your help they want your
solution right
yeah I was she she just has no issues uh
you know coming to me again and again
and again and again and a nibble here
and a bite here and you know I I know
that the big bite is coming but hold on
but hold on hold on why wouldn't she
come to you because you give it to every
time
right I know and so at this point I
don't even blame you you're a Dependable
enabler yeah I don't blame her anymore
I am I am and you know it's it's the
nibbles I don't mind and I know that
this is not the bad thing to say but
that's what got her to the bite
and you know next thing I know she's
telling me that she rents she rents her
house because she's been bankrupt Etc so
she can't get a mortgage and she can't
frankly afford a mortgage down here
anymore
um so she came to me because she needed
money for movers she needed money for
her security deposit her first month
last month which I did all of that
uh and then I sort of dug into a
finances and realized that you can't
even afford this rent so I tried to get
ahead of that and fortunately I'm doing
very well for myself and my family but
I'm doing well for myself and my family
and I've got two young children and a
wife and a mortgage and a business to
run
um so I I just so how long how long has
this been going on
oh I mean her financially no you giving
her money I'm you giving her money how
long has that been going on uh probably
five six seven years how old is she
about 73. oh wow
and she's Stone broke
yeah and recently widowed which only you
know made me softer Am I by my
stepfather passed two years ago three
years ago so obviously that I was trying
to help and what do you make
uh Family household income is probably
three quarters of a million okay and
um so it's not a matter of you can't or
can you can mathematically yeah it's a
matter of what's good for her she's 73
she's probably not very employable
um I guess she has social security job
I'm sorry she does have a full-time job
she does have a full-time job okay I
retract that statement what does she do
uh she's a uh customer service and she
has been for about 20 years the same job
but you know
she's one fall away from yeah not being
able to work anymore yeah okay so
I'll tell you the financial answer and
I'll let John tell you the psychological
answer okay uh the financial answer if
I'm in your shoes is I'm gonna sit down
with her and say mom you have this
coming in
from your Social Security you have this
coming in from your job
and these are your bills Let's do let's
do a budget together
and um you can make your bills or you're
within 400 of making your bills or
whatever it is okay and uh so I am not
going
to write checks
just from today on without us having a
sense of control over what's going on
here so I'll help you and Coach you with
your money but um it looks to me like
you have enough to live on
and I'll help you and Coach you live on
that or if you don't have enough to live
on I'm gonna give you two thousand
dollars a month so that you have enough
to live on this 24 000 out of 750 000
you can afford it but you say this is
what we're doing but then the she needs
to
um just it it's you're becoming bitter
and I would too yes because you feel
like an ATM machine
exactly and then there's an entitlement
that goes with this on her end and so I
would shut all of that down and just say
okay this is a system and we're going to
live by this system and uh draw some
boundaries and Mom if you don't want to
do that what I'm if you don't want to
live on the budget that you and I put
together and that I check on you to make
sure you're living on that budget then
um then I'm not going to help you
anymore
and you're gonna have to just figure it
out because it's not good for you what
I've been doing and I'm sorry I've let
you down John what would you do yeah I I
wonder if you're more frustrated with
yourself than with her right now oh no
yeah
yeah it's just every time I try to get
ahead of it you know for example when
she was looking at this rent
um I said you know what I'm just gonna
buy her an apartment and then she can
just pay me you know what she can afford
I I was going to buy her an apartment
outright and I was scrambling because
she was looking for a rental and she
couldn't afford none of these places
could she afford because we kind of not
a deep dive but we looked at our
finances
and then I realized okay it's this is
just easier for me to buy an apartment
at least then I can consider it a
quote-unquote investment of some sort
um and I presented her with it and she
said no I don't want to live there I'm
just going to rent this other place and
hold on and that's where you who are
clearly
a special businessman to be able to make
the money you make
you're clearly very smart and I would be
willing to bet nobody in your in your
sphere
blows past you like that but she does
right and I don't want you to consider
um sitting out at the table and saying
I'm looking that you at the fact that
you may be around until you're 93 20
more years
we have to put some things in concrete
right now
I want you to tattoo this phrase on the
middle of your forehead choose guilt
over resentment every time
because right now you're backing
yourself into a corner because you won't
set boundaries and you're beginning
every time your mom calls you get angry
yes and your mom quite frankly deserves
better than that and that means you have
to set the boundaries up and then she is
a 73 year old adult can say I hate you
you don't even love me and you walk away
she's a grown-up and she gets to do that
I would hate that but she gets to do
that your job is to create boundaries
that are sustainable for 20 years from
this point forward and by the way sit
with your wife and you all decide what
y'all are going to do to help her
um before you sit down with your with
your mom yeah how much you're willing to
do but the unlimited
thread being pulled on the sweater is
killing both of you yeah you got to cut
it just general observation over 30
years of doing this on the air and
working with people
um one of the
I'll just make it up top five pain
points
that people have with money
is
um
how to properly
be compassionate kind loving
to uh extended family grown children
that have problems how do we you know
children that are out of the house or
that should be out of the house uh
parents brother sister
uh extended family
uh that that we see that they have a
need or they bring us a need either one
and then how to appropriately deal with
that the whole issue of boundaries Dr
Henry Cloud sold 10 million boundaries
books off of that concept
but the whole our Buddy Henry but the uh
uh that whole issue is
you know mathematically it probably
causes almost as much disruption in
someone's wealth building Journey as
anything else
keeps you from becoming wealthy
and is it the lack of when I don't fully
unders understand what my values are on
money when I fully don't understand my
own footing
is that where is that where the
challenges come from I don't know I
don't want family members in my mind
it's reduced simply to we don't know how
to establish proper boundaries and a
boundary can be that I agree to help
somebody a boundary can be I agree to
say I decided I'm going to say no but we
don't have that
cut that part of our compass
is as it's as toxic as some families are
but it's like that last caller gets mad
that somebody keeps coming into space
but he's never done the work to Define
his space exactly and so you have to do
the hard work and say this is for me and
my house this is what we make that's
what we have is what we can do and then
ask would we do that and why and those
are questions that people don't like to
ask well but I mean when you're uh
there's a book called Glass Castle uh
that is a a lady that was a MSNBC
reporter
um very well known and she was raised in
an extremely weird toxic dysfunctional
family both of her parents as she's an
adult were living on the street in New
York while she's working at MSNBC wow
they were homeless wow they chose that
but they were kooky but um I mean it's a
great read just because it's like oh
just in case you thought your family was
crazy you know I think but the uh uh but
yeah but the uh
you know she felt helpless to fix them
but they chose homelessness in that case
um you can't make these adults behave
the only thing you can control is your
space and that's so hard for people oh
it's so hard it's so hard but like that
last caller there has there I guess
let's say this way there will be a
confrontation yep that will happen and
the earlier you can have it the the
lower it tends to be and so in that last
situation where he's thinking I'm just
going to buy her an apartment I found
one that I can afford I'll write a check
for it and call it good and she said I'm
not living there that's when the
conversation happens then I'm not
putting a penny towards the choices
you're choosing to make yeah you can you
can figure it out I'm not doing that
this is open invitation for you right
here and that's a hard conversation but
she has no motivation to even not live
where she wants to because she knows
he's gonna give me the money yeah and um
it's the same way with kids the same
with neighbors the same way with family
members but there's a
Cloud talks about and I guess there's
the first chapter maybe even in that
book
um
that when you
set a boundary with someone who doesn't
respect boundaries
100 of the time you can expect a
negative reaction always pouting
guilt-tripping anger
none of them go oh well I never thought
of it that way I'm so sorry and think of
it like you built a fence and your
neighbors throwing rocks at it hitting
it with sticks everyone's going to use
the tools that they have to try to get
you to open the gate up and don't yeah
and that's hard that's just a boundary
but man it is really it's hard it causes
more heartache uh and literally then
does end up driving a wedge between a
husband and wife because one of them's
helping the other ones
I'm choosing my uh my crazy brother who
won't get a job over my wife's wishes
you know and that drives a wedge in
their marriage and it just it slows down
wealth building and it's not to say you
can't help extended family or you
shouldn't help but this idea that we're
morally obligated to meet their every
wish
just because they hit the DNA Lottery
and happen to be kin to us I think it's
the I think it's something else okay I
actually think
um
if you if you flip this conversation on
its head we use our family members
to help us feel better about ourselves I
don't want to be uncomfortable that my
mom is in position X or Y so I'm just
gonna do whatever and when you do that
you're actually consuming her you're
using her
to make you feel better and I'm not
going to do that I'm going to sit in the
discomfort so that we're all better 5 10
15 20 years from now
um it's like going to the gym and taking
all the weights off the bar that that
sure makes the workout easier but ain't
nobody get any stronger and so I'm not
going to use my 14 year old and her
approval
to make me feel better about myself I'm
gonna have the hard conversation so you
can't talk like that in this home and
it's really when you say choose guilt
over resentment it's also you could be
choosing their anger
over resentment yeah of course it could
be choosing their disapproval over
resentment
whatever whatever way they choose to hit
back when you draw a boundary
um over
resentment right because you're going to
be resentful if you remain in the
enabler seat right and your spouse is
going to be 10x as resentful as you are
if you remain in the enabler C and in a
less caustic situation let's say my mom
calls and says or sends an email and
says we want y'all to come to Christmas
a whole family's coming we're really
expecting you all to be there
and we can't travel this year or our
family's exhausted we don't have the
money whatever
I can say yes and the whole time I'm
driving there I'm gonna be mad at her
the whole time I'm sitting at the meal
I'm gonna be mad that's not fair to her
it's fair to her to say we're not coming
we're unable to make that trip this year
we're not gonna be able to do it and
then she gets to be an adult and do
whatever reactions on the back end of
that she wants to do but the fair thing
is I'm not gonna spend a weekend not
liking my mom
I'd rather feel guilt I'd rather listen
to her responses than to sit there and
smolder the whole weekend and by the way
your kids learn how to treat in-laws
when you do that or your mother when you
do that you're modeling to everybody how
to live I'm just not going to do that
anymore I'm gonna set the boundaries and
they're going to be hard and I have to
be in a position to let other adults
walk away if they don't approve or like
my boundaries on something
you know I think Sharon and I went to
the extreme other end on that we may
have messed up the other way what's that
um
we don't put any expectations
for the holidays and uh and we have
fallen in love with our in-laws so
Winston's mom and dad I mean Winston's
going on Dad's going on a hunting trip
with me in two weeks yeah you know
without Winston yeah and without my son
you know and because buddy and I like
each other you know and so buddy and
Helen and Dave and Sharon do stuff the
same same with uh Bill's parents same
with Allison's parents so the in-laws
were actually friends with them and we
made that an intentional act that's cool
but they're also cool people that's cool
and uh you know we'll travel together I
mean Buddy's gone you know we've gone to
Mexico together done other stuff and so
that's cool that we've gone on golfing
trips with all of us all the guys all
three all three grandpas that's pretty
cool that's fun so um you know we'll do
that kind of stuff but we intend it and
then when Thanksgiving comes up and the
kids go huh we're going to Kansas City
to Allison's parents good yeah you
should knock it out should and um then
we'll just figure it out we see you all
the time by the way they're all they're
here they're all here in Nashville so
yeah so we got it made in that regard
but it doesn't it's not like we're
perfect or something but we just went to
the extreme of full release yeah and the
happiness the secret to happiness is low
expectations hello but there's a strange
phenomenon Dave that when you fully
release it it tends to come back it
tends to come back but it works out it
does it works out because again it's
just if you don't have these
expectations you don't say screwed up
and torqued out all the time that's
right and that's the same true of
somebody else's money and the people
want to be around you and you're not
twerked out all the time it just tends
to work that way yeah and again that's a
type of boundary situation so this is
very interesting discussion it's
something I've observed here for 30
years so setting boundaries with
extended family on money